das virus ist natürlich nicht nur hier
in deutschland sondern in ganz europa
auf der ganzen welt ein großes problem
das immer schlimmer wird er in spanien
gibt es immer mehr opfer jetzt in der
von 24 stunden wurden 800 weitere tote
dort nun vermeldet die krankenhäuser
werden dementsprechend natürlich auch
immer voller mittlerweile landesweit
mehr als 40.000 patienten die in
krankenhäusern betreut werden müssen ein
zustand der natürlich die pfleger die
ärzte und die krankenhäuser einfach an
ihre grenzen kommen lässt wir haben in
madrid mit einem notarzt aus einer der
überfüllten kliniken spaniens gesprochen
das hospital silva ist eines der
krankenhäuser spaniens mit den meisten
corona patienten eine der am stärksten
überfüllten kliniken des landes
wir tun was wir können alles was in
unserer macht steht wie sie sich
vorstellen können sind wir selber lastet
mit großer physischer und emotionaler
anstrengung
es ist eine außergewöhnliche situation
die wir logischerweise bewältigen so gut
wir können aber das ist wirklich eine
enorme anstrengung
weil es so viele sind und emotional weil
du den ganzen tag im ausnahmezustand
bist mit kranken die angst haben und
familien die sie nicht sehen können
natürlich müssen wir manchmal die
patienten aufmuntern
vor allem die alten menschen die jungen
leute haben handys und tablets um mit
ihren familien zu kommunizieren
aber die alten können das nicht diese
müssen wir aufmuntern ihnen gut zu reden
damit sie nicht untergehen wenn man auf
tage lang in der notaufnahme liegt
streckt irgendwann der kopf und
umgekehrt genauso
das ist eine sehr emotionale situation
aber jeden tag um 8 wird applaudiert
jeden tag das treibt einen an
das ist sehr bewegend wenn du die
menschen sie ist wie sie krank da liegen
mit ihren masken an schläuchen hängt
angeschlossenen sauerstoffflaschen und
trotzdem finden sie um 20 uhr die kraft
uns zu applaudieren
es gibt noch eine weitere initiative für
die helden
ich glaube aber die wahren helden sind
die die an den krankenhäusern liegen
man schenkt uns krohn krohn aus papier
[Musik]